precisamente esta quincuagésima segunda
asamblea de la organización de los
Estados Americanos se ha inaugurado esta
noche en Lima con los ojos puestos en
Nicaragua y el sentimiento es atender la
situación que se vive en ese país
precisamente conversamos con Ricardo
Pérez quien es presidente de la Corte
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos él me
señaló que van a proponer a la corte que
los países integrantes realicen una
posición muy fuerte en cuanto al
gobierno del presidente de Daniel Ortega
para que obedezca una sanción de la
Corte Interamericana de Derechos Humanos
que ordena que se liberen a 45 personas
que están prisioneras en ese país por
otro lado también conversamos con la
vocera del departamento de estado de los
Estados Unidos Cristina Rosales ella nos
señaló que Estados Unidos va a impulsar
una posición para que se luche por la
situación que se vive en Haití para que
se restablezca la democracia a través de
elecciones libres y también se trabaje
en líneas de acción para atender la
crisis alimentaria que esos momentos
sufren miles de personas en ese país
importante y hay preocupación a nivel
continental por estos dos países en
Francisco que otros temas van a ser
abordados también en este encuentro
los más de 25 cancilleres que asisten a
esta asamblea que por primera vez se
realiza presencialmente porque dos años
como sea recordarán se ha estado con la
crisis de la pandemia del Kobe 19 ellos
van a trabajar también para impulsar una
declaración para que se detenga la
guerra en Ucrania y retornando a nuestra
región también van a establecer
políticas que permitan la igualdad de
las personas se cierren la brecha
sociales y precisamente como usted lo
mencionó el lema de esta asamble es
luchar para Elevar la igualdad y
precisamente el presidente Pedro
Castillo quien es anfitrión de esta
asamblea le pidió a los cancilleres a
trabajar todos juntos en unidad para
cerrar la brecha sociales que existen e
impulsar la calidad de vida de las
personas que se encuentran en
vulnerabilidad en toda la región y se
permita un mayor crecimiento para
todos